après les attentats à paris une nouvelle
a circulé elle laisse à croire que les
terroristes étaient coordonnés par
l'entremise de console de jeu vidéo
playstation 4 nouvelles qui est loin
d'être avérée mais après de telles
attaques
ces communications cryptées sont souvent
pointés du doigt mathieu bonsoir sa
cellule alors éclairé nous un peu
comment est-ce qu'on allait arriver à
penser ça mais en fait c'est un article
du magazine forbes le week end dernier
que mis le feu aux poudres en fait
l'article déformé les propos du ministre
belge de l'intérieur qui dans une
entrevue avant les attentats a affirmé
que le mode de communication entre le
terroriste le plus difficile à
surveiller
c'est la ps4 alors là on est parti avec
cela on a carrément déformé ses propos
donc c'est pas avery de cette nouvelle
n'a pas été déposé sk pas quand même un
danger réel vraiment réel que on se
servent des réseaux de consoles de jeux
vidéo pour justement organisé les
acteurs on devait effectivement et
d'ailleurs c'est pour ça aussi que les
agents sont là depuis longtemps vous
savez sur les jeux massivement
multijoueurs comme world of warcraft
depuis plusieurs années il ya des
agendas secrets qui sont qui font partie
de ces joueurs là donc ils ont des
amateurs ils sont parmi les
conversations qui s'y trouvent pour voir
s'il n'y a pas quelque chose
d'inquiétant qui s'y dit mais aussi il
faut pas oublier que l'ensemble de nos
communications par exemple et pas
seulement celles par le truchement des
jeux vidéo sont touchés par ce biais des
applications comme temps mais c'est un
jeu comme ces gnomes comme what's app
qui est très populaire qui servent à
envoyer des communications cryptées
s'est pas seulement le jeu vidéo ou le
qu'on doit mettre en cause va quand on
parle de communication cryptée
mais alors qu'est ce qu'il faut penser
de toutes ces voix qui s'élèvent ont pas
même du patron de la cia john brennan
thiam les rendent si communication là en
ligne plus transparent mais à chaque
attentat c'est la même chose dans cette
arrivée lors des attentats de charlie
hebdo au mode de 2 janvier david cameron
avait dit là il faut supprimer la
cryptographie au royaume uni et écouter
s'est fait ramasser par à peu près tout
ce qu'il ya de cet expert en
cybersécurité parce que je vous donnais
une analogie comme par exemple les
greffes et doivent prendre des
médicaments immuno suppresseurs mais
d'enlever la cryptographie de nos
réseaux ça affaiblit l'ensemble du
réseau
gens qui disaient d'ailleurs si vous
faites ça au royaume-uni là vous allez
retourner à l'âge de pierre
parce qu'imaginez le système bancaire
avec plus de cryptographie imaginez la
cryptographie qu'on enlève des systèmes
de gestion de l'énergie
imaginez la cryptographie qu on
enlèverait par exemple de dossiers
médicaux des gens qui sont en ligne et
dont on affaiblit les capacités jal
intervient en danger après mettre la vie
des gens en danger est d'ailleurs une
journaliste de techcrunch qui a très
bien résumé ça c'est une maladie et je
la cite les appels à la fin des
communications chiffrées constitue un
aveu d'échec des programmes de
surveillance de masse face au terrorisme
pas simple non non merci beaucoup
maintien et plaisir